So we're asked, "how many liters of
soda do we have for the party?"
And they give us all of this other
information.
I encourage you to pause this video
and think about which of this information
you actually need to answer this first
question and then try to answer the question:
"How many liters of soda do we have
for the party?" So pause now.
Let's look at this information:
"20 people are coming to the party."
This doesn't let us know how many liters we actually have.
So we know we can ignore this.
"We have purchased 5 bottles of soda for the party."
Well, this seems useful - we're going to have 5 bottles of soda.
So that's 1... 2... 3.... 4.... and 5 bottles of soda.
That's this piece of information right over here.
If only we now knew how much soda is in each bottle.
"The party will last for 3 hours." This has nothing
to do with how many liters of soda we have.
"Each bottle has 2 liters of soda." This
is interesting.
This is 2 liters... this is 2 liters... this is 2 liters...
this is 2 liters... and that is 2 liters.
If we wanted to figure out the total number
of liters of soda we have,
We have 5 bottles, and each of them are
2 liters each. So we have 5 times 2
And what is that equal to?
5 times 2 is the same thing as
2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2
You have five 2's added together.
Let me write this down...
Which is equal to: 2, 4, 6, 8, 10.
5 times 2 is 10.
We have 10 liters of soda for the party.
We're able to answer it without even looking
at this last one. This last one tells us how
many bottles of soda we had for the picnic last week.
which doesn't seem related at all
to our current party.